where did you come from today to visit
the carnival I came from the beautiful
city of Denver Colorado Wow there are a
lot of Tartans out there a few of us
votes to 800 of them okay great why did
you come here originally it was kind of
a fluke how I found Carnegie Mellon I
was looking for a school that had a
really strong mathematically oriented
business program in a big city and in
the computer ages of the late 80s
Carnegie Mellon just kept coming up on
the computer again and again and again
and so finally we decided to as a family
you know let's go ahead and let's apply
to the school and see what happens and
we got in and my dad took me down here
spring of nineteen eighty nine and I
fell in love with the place in Walla was
the carnegie mellon student that
following fall you are hooked so now
that you're hooked tell me some stuff
about like how do you show your tart and
pride shoma tartan pride pretty much
every day wearing my class ring wherever
I go whether it's the gym whether it's
at a business meeting whether it's a
client call my kids are decked out in
Carnegie Mellon attire all the time my
five-year-old is constantly saying mom
I'm going to Carnegie Mellon she in fact
told her kindergarten teacher she wanted
to skip first grade and go straight on
to Carnegie Mellon my husband is also a
Carnegie Mellon alum he is the local
president of our alumni chapter and I
also show my pride by continuing to stay
involved locally here with my Greek
organization I was involved with as well
as the Alumni Association Board that's
fantastic why is it so important for us
to contribute to our university what are
some of the big reasons that you feel
there are it's important to continue and
contribute for the future students
coming in to continue to maintain the
fantastic facilities the you know the
the environment in terms of academics I
mean it's a whole it's a whole list of
why we should contribute just to
continue the saga of Carnegie Mellon and
continue to make it grow into the grey
and greater University that it has
become and will continue to be